my first name is undress last name is
Alonzo chief executive officer of the
Baltimore City Public Schools
well I'm the head of a large urban
school district I have 201 schools
83,000 kids 12,000 employees 6600 of
them teachers because I'm the the face
of the district the work is about
interacting with with parents with
stakeholders because I'm the lead
manager in the district it's also about
visiting schools meeting principles
having the kinds of interactions that
are about the operations of the district
I try to be in schools three four times
a week it's not always possible and it's
it's a 24-7 job with very long hours
lots of frustration but also lots of
energy and and and great great moments
in terms of what we see in classrooms
and in schools
problem of course is chronic
underachievement we had a school system
where traditionally fewer than fifty
percent of the kids were graduating
every single year it was also a school
system that over time I lost tens of
thousands of our students from its
enrollment part of it because the city
went from a city of a million people in
the 1960s to a city with 600,000 people
in the early two thousand lights of
poverty serious crime issues tremendous
issues of compliance in terms of its
relationship with with the state a 25
year old special education law suit that
has just refused to go away so many many
issues are similar in some cases
unfortunately to the issues that other
cities like Detroit Cleveland DC have
had over time but with their own unique
flavoring of course and the work for me
from the beginning was about first of
all create a sense of energy and hope
about the district a sense that out that
we were going to get the kids to
graduate give parents the choices that
that they had felt over time that in
half which caused them to leave
establish norms of accountability and
norms of effectiveness in the district
and engage engage engage with with
parents teachers business community
folks so that we we would all reach a
consensus about what needed to be done
in the schools in you know three years
into the job on my I'm on my 31st month
in the job I think that we have been
remarkably successful in terms of
beginning to turn around
a school district and having quick wins
and making significant leaps in a
relatively short amount of time
what what's interesting is that I
arrived with with a blueprint I think
it's very dangerous to go into into a
context and assume that because it's
work someplace else it's going to work
there in many ways it's the context
itself needs to tell you what needs to
happen there there there are certain
things that are that are the answer
wherever you go I mean you have to have
teachers that are prepared you have to
you have to provide the necessary
resources to support the schools you
have to you know establish certain norms
of effectiveness that everybody strives
toward the decisions have to be made on
the basis of what's good for kids that
in a way might be the most important
things to establish because if the
decisions are made on many different
basis political basis for example then
no one should be surprised that the
systems women don't improve so because
of of you know this this philosophy part
of what I did at the beginning was just
to listen so within the first two months
on the job for example i went to
community forums that allowed me to talk
two to three thousand people before
school begun and out of those
conversations things emerge tasks
emerged it was very clear for example
the parents want a choice it was very
clear that they wanted new settings in
sixth grade and ninth grade it was very
clear that they wanted to be engaged
they felt that that the school system
had sort of pushed them away there was a
kind of obsession with with making
adequate yearly progress with meeting No
Child Left Behind objectives in part
because the city had never made a YP in
any of its dimensions so a lot of the
work that we then did and
and we we spent a lot of energy and on
creating new schools on on expanding
alternative options on working with
teachers about new ways of collaborating
for example all those elements are
emergent it just seems so so clear that
that that's what the seriously involved
people were telling us needed to be to
happen and everything has been a
response to a process of engagement with
certain clear sort of foundational
pieces the focus on achievement I
believe that the community has to be
brought in because so much of the
history of the district has been about
the community exiting a choice and
competition as key elements of the work
since again so much of the history of
the district has been about a lack of
choice so that the poorest kids have the
fewest options in a competition because
the district was allowed to stagnate for
so long and then a combination of
autonomy and accountability at the
school level that allows the schools to
make the decisions that need to be made
for their own kids everything has sort
of stem from those key elements
what's so much of what happens in
schools is about somehow not trying to
transgress on the interest of adults so
from a symbolic perspective in order to
ensure that everybody knew that that
everybody had skin in the game because I
many of those many of the schools that
we chose to close had been really toxic
environments in terms of their outcomes
for kids over time because it seemed to
us that if we were going to create
settings that were going to work for
kids in a transformation away over time
we needed to we needed to give people a
chance in in in terms of starting new
new communities and settings that that
had truly different cultures we chose to
close schools it's it's an
extraordinarily hard endeavor because
one of the things that are that every
superintendent who tries this
immediately learns is that it doesn't
matter how bad a school is the community
doesn't want to close you have schools
where you know twenty five percent of
the kids are performing a proficient and
advanced or where you know thirty
percent of the kids have have graduated
and you have people coming to tell you
that no no it's not it's not about the
schools it's about the school not
getting support there's also a sense in
neighborhoods schools are very much part
of the history of neighborhoods and
anybody who dares to close a school in
some way is is violating a story arc for
that neighborhood people graduated from
that school quite often you have
teachers who who attended the school and
there's always is this the sense that
that the central office has not done its
job
which for us was was you know something
that we admitted from the start us and
this is not about the school's per se
this is about how a system has accept a
failure of a time and if we're if we're
going to succeed then we need to
understand that that there has to be a
process of renewal and and we need to
give new schools a chance so it wasn't
hard for us in terms of making the
decision it was hard to implement it we
closed six schools last year we're
closing another five this year we just
announced it on Tuesday we're already
launched in that process of having
conversations with community that that
takes tremendous energy from staff and
you know we it does by the way that this
is debate about whether the way to
improve school systems is to close
schools or to turning them around I mean
I think it takes everything we close
some we turn some around and turns of of
bringing in new programs but but the
closure of the worst performing schools
I think it's absolutely necessary as
long as we're providing something that
is better as part of the exchange so
it's been a hard thing for us to do but
something that I think is making the
district much better we've become
predictable which is which is a really
good thing in terms of how how
organizations work you know principles
understand that if the outcomes go down
there are certain consequences and the
consequences are not simply about the
kids it's about what happens to to an
institution right now for example I'm
recommending the non-renewal of a
charter it will be the first time that I
charter is none
you'd in a in the district and the
reason for that is that you know here is
a school that has all the autonomy in
the world the district is advancing the
school is regressing well you know the
school loses the Charter in the same way
that a traditional school might be
closed
well you know at some level accountable
to me I said because if I've been hired
to do certain things in one of those
things have been articulated then then
you know I you know man I don't have too
much patience with with you know the the
abstract notion it's it's you know you
ultimately everybody's accountable to me
ah that's why it's easy to close certain
schools because you know I'm holding
them accountable we have said this is
what needs to happen if it's not
happening fast enough then there's just
an accountability point that we all have
to address in the larger sense the
accountability is to to a community in
it's very very hard to get communities
to agree on what accountability means as
in everybody wants every kid to graduate
but when schools don't graduate half the
kids they don't want those schools to go
away so part of the work of leadership
is to make sure that that tension is
very clear to everybody if we are we are
in an age where accountability is being
defined in terms of test scores in term
and and when it's being done well is
test scores that are related to growth
and to into games when it's not being
done well it's it's it's about absolute
that sometimes have nothing to do with
the value of the work being done in
school I believe that quite often
something very important is being missed
at the same time I have very little
patience with with people who rail
against tests when when if you were
about their own kids that would be going
crazy if their kids were not able to do
well on an essay T exam because that
would mean that they wouldn't be getting
to you know the college that they could
be proud about so I think it's a complex
conversation but but at some level the
work has been about making it simple why
how are we as a system going to define
what what growth means how are we going
to be able to distinguish among schools
so that the conversation about what is a
good school changes you know a good
school is not a school where the middle
class kids go a good school is a school
that is that is achieving progress for
large numbers of kids a good school is
also a school that a community you know
endorses not by showing up when I say
the school is closing but by having you
know a hundred parents on a
back-to-school night and I'm a clearly
easy relationship in terms of the
conversations that are taking place
among kids so I mean it's it's all these
things I enter the conversation and but
there's no way to avoiding a harshness
in the conversation if the work is going
to be meaningful about fast change in a
district that has been stagnating all
the time
it looks like it's sort of going away on
its own right now I seen you have raised
to the top you know taking the salience
in how states and districts are
orienting their work it still matters
tremendously in in terms of how schools
in the public sort of see local
accountability I started teaching at a
time when the special education and you
know our classrooms were all in the
basement and those were the classrooms
that got the books last because they
didn't count in the test course so
there's this an element of No Child Left
Behind that I have always applauded
which is that it it it expanded the
demand for hard work in progress to
every single child I think it did it
very bluntly and with with huge
consequences in terms of narrowing of
instruction it was also in many ways to
too timid in that it never defined
standards it it left untouched questions
of equity as in you know it called for
highly qualified teachers but it did
nothing about making sure that they
ended up in the poorer schools or a call
for choice but it made choice within
districts well what if the district's
don't have enough good schools for
choice it didn't open up the choice to
the adjacent suburb where you know all
the middle class kids are so you know it
was very bold in some ways it was very
very timid and others clearly in many
things about it now change the
accountability system will be different
the move towards common standards is has
extraordinary but
ah city right now the nature of the test
is going to change so you know I'm
intrigued by what happens in the next
couple of years because it potentially
reorients everything and one of the
amazing things that are that the new
administration has done is its settle
very early on a change in practice
before the you know the big the big
leaver for the federal government was
was money as always and but the money
always went out you know in in a formula
what what has been happening is that the
money has huge amounts of money are now
discretionary they're being distributed
in a discretionary way and that has
created Stampede tours these dollars and
of course everybody trying to qualify
for the dollars in ways that has
completely shifted how you know certain
states are looking at the work you know
it's quite impressive I mean I give I
give the Secretary of Education enormous
credit for this you know it I don't
think I would have been able to think of
it so so I applaud him
I never watched it i'm familiar with it
you know why I've never watched it first
of all people think it's an amazing show
and they always react to me and saying
you know how could you not have watched
a wife and uh it's you know when I
decided that I was going to go to
Baltimore and everybody said you have to
have watched the fire wire and you have
to watch the fourth season that's a
season that it's about education ah it
just struck me know if I'm going to give
the city a chance i can i can approach
it through the lens of a work of fiction
however magnificent it might be that
shows it in its worst light and you know
i love people in schools too much how to
do that to them so I and of course you
know I taught in newark new jersey for
12 years so i felt that i don't need to
watch the TV show to you know to
understand what happens in in some of
the you know urban the core of america
so I've decided that I that I that I
wouldn't watch it and I'm just too busy
to to you know to watch like 150 hours
of TV however long it might take right
now so you know I haven't watched on HBO
series since the sopranos and of course
the sopranos i watch because I'm from
New Jersey but so that's the story of
the wire for me
I'll just tell you about a moment of
frustration a moment of frustration I
walked into into the classroom without
ever having had an education course had
been a lawyer sort of like fell into
this environment where i was running a
program and i was teaching and i had had
class they were emotionally disturbed
adolescents aged 11 through 14 and
because it was self-contained settings
you had kids ranging from like 11 years
old to 14 the kid who was completely in
grade level to the kid who didn't read
and that's a kid that I'll always
remember his name was Ivan who bright
bright bright right now I mean I know
that this is a kid it was completely
dyslexic nobody ever like diagnose what
he had and ended up in a classroom floor
emotionally disturbed kids there was
nothing emotionally disturbed about this
kid he just couldn't function in a
school and nobody have figured out a way
to approach him so I remember going to
my principal a woman named Wilma Finley
and this must have happened like within
the first month that I was that I was a
teacher and basically reaching out to
her and just saying you know what I just
don't know how to teach this kid you
know I don't know how to teach eivin i
sit with him every single day for 45
minutes figure out a way to give him 45
minutes or one and one structure I come
back the next day it's like we've done
nothing the day before and and I always
remember her telling me I you know sort
of like there's a key you know just
looking for the just keep looking for
the key keep looking for keep look keep
looking for the key she was she was a
great influence and and so when I when I
think of
classrooms and think of kids you know I
always I always think of that kid in
that name it's it's a very important
thing for me I mean this idea whoa you
know why don't we do with Ivan right and
that and also that idea that you know
you might have tried 35 things but
there's a key that you haven't found and
of course it informs the way that I
think because I was so unprepared and
and the systems were not in place back
then the knowledge might not have been
in place while you know while today I
think that we have we have in places
that have gotten their act together they
they are they're just different ways of
ensuring that somebody who walks into a
classroom with without the necessary
knowledge you know gains you know the
hooks you know it's able to have the
kinds of conversations so that they
don't they don't walk into a room and
say you know like I just don't know how
to do this so that that's very much at
the core of how I see the work I think
that there is a key and I think that we
all benefit from saying sometimes I just
have no clue how to approach this I
think adults have have a hard time with
that